and Alanis Morissette was also at last
night's billboard women in music event
to accept the icon award and when she
took to the stage Alice Alanis gave a
powerful speech and admitted it was hard
being a young female musician back in
the 1990's have a look it was a slightly
isolating experience Fame is very
strange thing it creates a social
context is not normal it's not normal I
was I was a watcher my whole life I was
an observer of humans I loved the human
condition so all of a sudden everyone's
eyeballs turned toward me and the irony
the real irony is that I loved
performing but I was really really
terrified to perform and didn't like it
at all
so my Stamper my temperament a lot of
people talk about bravery and you know
so much courage to be a woman in music
and empowerment and while I will always
stand by that I just want to salute the
women who continue to go to work who are
really really sensitive and terrified
and still go as Taylor mentioned it was
an unusual time of me playing with a lot
of different gentleman bands and it was
challenging because if there was not
going to be any sex or any romantic
interaction then they didn't know what
to do with me
so they ignored me backstage
Wow I mean that event just seems like it
was fantastic I've been watching some of
the speeches this morning
I think it's powerful stuff it is an
Alanis Morisette the 90s that's what it
was all about we all looked up to her I
actually played basketball with her in
Toronto when she first started off yes
McCormick says is called the the center
on Parkdale area okay no anyways but
from some point on I mean I love our try
to get her tickets yesterday as well but
it is powerful she deserves the iconic
award everything that she has done in
her music is so powerful Jackie Little
Pill was one of my favorite albums as
well but you write their speeches are
incredible and women are speaking up to
support each other beautiful I love
events like this when it's not it's an
award that you know they can take that
award go onstage and say what they're
truly feeling and the things that they
experienced